Kathryn Bigelow's Detroit is pure social
justice warrior propaganda I'll explain
that in the following review in a
nutshell it's a big steaming pile of
horse Kathryn Bigelow's Detroit Oscar
Bates it's like the term Oscar bait was
created for this film not gay jarred
yours truly and actually pops Crowder
went to go see the film today and we'll
give you a full review here in a minute
the good the bad and the ugly
he actually I should say this was raised
in Detroit during the riots so uh that's
why it's here we keep them hidden let me
say this around the outset it is
textbook propaganda and I kid you I
bring up the textbook definition of
propaganda and what I mean by that is
they deliberately spread misinformation
to malign a specific group of people as
you see through the the definition who's
that group okay
well we'll get into whether it's just a
good movie standalone and then we'll get
into what is accurate what they got
right in what they got wrong they got
nearly all of it wrong but look after
you save the word literally I throw that
out there to me and like like
figuratively no no no I'm throwing out
to mean literally nearly everything
wrong so let's see some other reviews
right off the bat let's see what they
have to say a couple of them from ABC
News this was America you think this is
still America wall street journal'
dramatically relentless and emotionally
shattering it brings news from a
turbulent past that casts a baleful
light on America's troubled present New
York Times just the headline review in
Detroit black lives caught in a
prehistory of the alt-right okay
now when I say propaganda to Milan is
specific group of people who is it not
only police officers which will get to
put specifically yeah white people no
I'm not turning this into a race war but
Kathryn Bigelow is she actually said
what better way to use your white
privilege on ironically use the term
white privilege than to undermine it
that is the goal of this film okay first
off before we get to the the message
where they got right or wrong did you
like it did you think it was well done
it was a well-done film especially from
his cinematography standpoint yeah it
looked good it felt nice that was about
all I can say for all she loves her
shaky she loves the shaky cam she just
shakes the hell out of that cam did what
did you
Thompson yeah plenty of grit it sure
looked it looked authentic when we saw
the actual real from the city but it was
a whole different tenor and tone when
they went to the the actual film stock
this is true I didn't really like it
that much
III thought The Hurt Locker was good I
saw dark thirty was they're all a bit
too long so if you're not a huge fan of
Bigelow's previous films with the the
jarring shaky-cam
and always a little bit too long just a
little bit self-indulgent this isn't
going to change your mind from that
perspective certainly not a pleasant
watch no pretty bleak which is I think
by design again used to push the
propaganda so here's were they what they
got wrong right off the bat let's talk
about the very first frames of the film
there's this animation where it talks
about black Americans coming from the
south promises of jobs to the north in
the Midwest Detroit and then somewhere
in there there couple things they say
the MIT equal opportunity was a myth it
was a lie and that one is completely
false because it's medevacked they
couldn't have picked the worst example
Detroit if you actually look at the
statistics black median family incomes
were about 95 percent that that's just
comparing the median income of black
families to white families now that's
not job for job so I'm not talking about
pay like wage gap statistics but that
matters because that gives you an idea
as to the class was there an underclass
in Detroit black families no 95 percent
of the standard income of white families
and about three to four percent
unemployment now after the riots all of
that skyrocketed right and it
disproportionately hurt black people
black people were disproportionately
killed by black people black people
disproportionately lost home ownership
their property values went downs but the
idea that it was a myth no you could
only make that claim after the riots and
then another thing in that I think it's
in that first intro they talk about how
the white fled to the suburbs and blacks
were restricted to specific areas of the
city it's a little sleight of hand cuz
it moves from it like as always policy
now you live in Detroit was there a
policy where you you stay in this block
absolutely did the only people I knew of
it we restrict what way usually
absolutely yeah there was a policy the
policy of restriction was police and
firemen could not leave the city of
Detroit they had to live in the
environment had the environs of the city
those the only people who were
restricted to it and that's great
where you lived that is your right
another little notch where all those
people lived well your your best
friend's dad mr. Patroni little friends
father's were policemen yeah they were
policemen now tell people who don't know
you were raising an in Detroit what what
you want well first off here's something
that's important because they use kind
of the crux of this is one of the main
characters use it spoiler alerts by the
way two people haven't watch it uses a
starter pistol and he's shooting
repeatedly at police officers with a
starter pistol
so think it's sniper fire now they refer
to this as a toy guns it's quarter
pistol so they can actually see flash
and gap gun sounds now what is use to
diminish the idea of sniper fire that
they were just trigger-happy police
officers by the way police officers
horrible well get to the individual the
motel case all of us agree terrible
abuse of the law fine but the context
matters what did your father was in the
Air Force what did he do train Detroit
riots at that time he led some Air
National Guard people that did
reconnaissance flights over the city of
Detroit in an RF 84 which was a plane
that was designed to take photos from
high altitude and high def photos at
that time for sniper fire and and and
fires and activity in the city rooftops
didn't you watch tanks go down down cagy
Road on the way to i-94 we set my
brother and I your Uncle Dean my older
brother sat on the mailbox and watched
him parade by tanks armored personnel
carriers yeah jeeps it was a war zone
yeah it was war the city was a war zone
I mean Yeti 100 that wasn't just
National Guard that was 82nd airborne
hardened 1st airborne yeah current
military yeah yeah yeah I was always a
big deal and that's important to note
because there's this film and this is
what's dangerous is intercuts real
footage of detroit fake footage now it
folks is it the the algier motel oh gee
uh yep algeria motel focus on that and
that is a very specific story they
choose where there are examples of
police brutality they weren't charged if
they weren't convicted if you look at
the court documents and they they'll
make quite a few facts but it is
interesting because this is again where
the propaganda comes in so they start
with misinformation they ignore
contextually the Detroit
and I think that's important because if
you actually looked at Detroit riots you
could say this could be a great learning
tool it hurt everybody
no one benefited and it most of all hurt
black families in Detroit black people
looting and killing black people it
really hurt the black community instead
when you make it about white privilege
you take something that could actually
be uniting where we could avoid these
conflicts in the future and people are
saying well it's more relevant cuz more
racist now than ever did we just have a
black president was I was that like it
was a day dreaming for eight years I
wish I wish that were the case Stephen
okay so there's there's real footage
intercut with fake footage which i think
is important because the fake footage so
the [ __ ] footage of shot and shot leg
real footage shows people really scared
like kids like steel looting groceries
yeah and then it cuts to the real
footage it's a bunch of people who are
stoned and cocky I get in the TV walked
out kicking in windows it shows footage
fake footage of a white woman stealing a
television set yeah and then real
footage of gang members again lighting
thing that's like you couldn't find one
instant you're putting in a fake we
could find one instance others the old
the old white lady carrying a TV sits
not one and she wasn't gonna keep
possession that TV so you know what was
the reality because they really that for
people who don't realize some people
won't know what is faking what is real
again because the shaky cam well what
you notice in the footage that the
actual footage versus the movie the film
is there's a power difference in the
actual footage who has the power it's
the protesters it's the rioters yeah and
in the real footage they make early in
the film footage they make it look as
though the cops have all the power right
knees people are the downtrodden the
beaten down the fearful and that the
real the actual footage belies all of
that and these people are in control
yeah well in the word and the people who
would be first targeted by snipers the
people would have it the worst of all
would be black police officers sure and
Detroit that's what they skim over that
at the end I forgot the name of the
actor from Star Wars
John boyega yeah John boyega he plays a
black security guard remember he's being
charged he's beat he's on trial with
these white guys and they get something
he's disgusted with these white cops who
are Grant absolutely disgusting from
what we know but they skim over Heath
led this to the suburbs immediately
afterward on a second he's a black black
skirt what was it the cop sending him
death threats you know this black police
officers in Detroit had to drive home in
unmarked cars
it was terrible sure you know all the
old terms Uncle Tom and and these guys
these guys had a lot I had a tough slog
for sure and the increased hiring of
black cops exponentially right after the
riots
right yeah it was a policy right and put
probably put them in a lot of danger as
well absolutely so we had a couple of
things here that that really struck me
so they here's what matters they focus
on one algier the motel right now you
watch this and you want to ring these
cops the eyebrows white guy his MO yeah
because it was like Ron Sid yes and you
watch it but the thing is if you look at
the reviews they say one can hardly
watch these without seeing the faces of
Trayvon Martin or Michael Brown well hon
a second are you trying to set these
people weren't innocent shot like
Michael brung his hands up don't shoot
was a lie and unfortunately because of
the lies from the left so consistently
it makes me watch this film and go wait
a second wait a second is that true so
in this film they make it seem again as
though they remove the context now if
you look at Detroit riots if you look at
Detroit 1960 to this very hour it's
pretty damning it's it's an all Democrat
city all black City Commission oh you
know it's all Democrat all black all the
time so if you if you look at if you
have to look you're gonna look about
checking your privilege we want to look
at systemic problems and corruption with
Detroit it's so clear do is okay alright
you can just see the wheels turning with
cat with bigelow okay we can't do it cuz
Detroit never was gonna see Democratic
mayor since 1961 they're gonna see black
worse now than ever yeah worse now than
ever okay let's okay let's take one
example that's clearly a really bad sort
of bad police officers police brutality
people executed okay so we can take that
let's take this ah crap it's not
necessarily black and white half these
kids have a rap sheet a mile long let's
address it in court later where and they
asked him if he was ever arrested no no
by the way guy was right some of these
people were mostly motion to strike that
question yeah not relevant ago did a
teacher
vini and then the two white girl
characters in the film I find it so
funny
so this is what they
this whole film is designed if you look
at they'll say hashtag not all cops I
backed the blue but this whole film is
designed to create one excuse of after
another just I've never did anything he
planted it all cops are planting weapons
all cops are corrupt it's this wall of
what happens sometimes but if you look
at what happened this film cops have
been charged for far less sure so
immediately it begs some questions and
they try to make it seem as though all
cops or racists because there are two
white girls there and what are you doing
sleeping with these and words are you a
prostitute
I would never sir well in reality if you
actually look at the case they had a
long criminal history police records of
being prostitutes which is not included
in the films of fabricated though these
are white girls by the way so none of
this justifies the behavior of the
police but again this this is and what I
just find important and this is what I
want to have you on the show to talk
about your experiences in Detroit ignore
the whole history nor the whole context
of the city Detroit 1960 to today focus
on one sir and what will they say well
because their story needs to be told so
we're gonna selectively tell this story
which vilifies police officers and as
Bigelow says undermines white privilege
brings it to the forefront we're gonna
pick this one story okay what about
picking the one story of the teacher who
was assaulted by these people in this
one story everyone has a story you can
take any one story make it bleak and
harrowing you could certainly do it from
the other side with the Detroit riots
and statistically measure it's
undeniable that the Detroit riots were
the result of leftist policies and
racially incited violence and hatred
from the left that's right I don't I
don't know what the goal of the film is
I don't know what they're trying to
doesn't certainly doesn't help race
relations does it create an excuse does
it create more more fear more tension I
don't know it's just I don't see where
it was going I think that's a good point
cuz about undermining white privilege
right that's what they say is so so that
starts with the premise of white
privilege and that starts with a premise
of we need undermining it we need to
undermine it meaning white people need
to feel guilty and she they couldn't
pick a worse example I never remember
feeling in control when I lived in
Detroit I remember I didn't feel like I
was going into the city to oppress you
know we were told to lock our doors and
mind their own business and roll the
stoplights because it was extremely
dangerous
hence they still do that there's nobody
left to kill the population is less than
you know a third of what it was when I
grew up there but I never felt in
control of anything I never saw that I
always I saw the other side of it what
the actual footage showed which was the
bullying and the mocking and the really
enjoying the violence and I grew up
thinking that's what it was like as you
went further into the city I think you
know you asked the question but I think
it's a very it's a good point what is
the goal of film and I think the goal of
the film oh you okay you were raised in
Detroit right the race riots in Detroit
okay how would you say race relations
are today in 2017 worse see they're
worse today worst across the country but
worse today because of what's been
ginned up in these last eight years you
see everything has been seen through the
lens of race and class and gender and
it's it's really getting tough now is
there systemic racism no what's gone
there is no impediment to your progress
anymore in education in media anywhere
now their individual races like we saw
in the film sure on both sides yeah but
I don't think there's any
institutionalized racism I think in the
60s it did they could make a case yeah
yeah for an uphill struggle sure they
could the worst example would be Detroit
because yet black people and all the
Democrats that were against the civil
rights movement right and it was it was
part of the model Cities program for
people who don't know we have two videos
in Detroit na kijiye and I have done in
the past where we have all of the
statistics regarding Detroit
unemployment what's the crazy kicked out
of the car and they're you know model
program was doing so well and there was
you know both black and white people
they were it was a mixed class this idea
that it's poverty there wasn't a black
underclass in Detroit until after the
riots it disproportionately harmed black
Americans which is why I would think if
our goal is really to make progress if
our goal is if the film's goal was to
make people rethink their their their
positions or to make people to unite
people across the racial divide to
actually educate people in ways they
could improve their neighborhoods and
specifically to benefit the black
community it claims to serve they should
address the fallout of the Detroit riots
and the policies thereof and say hey
this is the cautionary tale don't do
that that's the opposite of what we want
to do you had some notes written down
you don't want most of my notes
yeah even though most of my notes are
not great and I think we talked about
there was a scene at the very beginning
it was like an animated kind of well
that was really bad and to go back to
something we talked about before I was
thinking okay it's Kathryn Bigelow
really that bad like I didn't really see
it really clearly in The Hurt Locker or
even in Syria dark thirty like it was
kind of soft propaganda and then you're
like no she's gotten bad I'm like okay
we'll see was it first second I was like
oh yeah it opened you know I wanted to
walk out like just it was so so bad
I'm very first phrases about the cotton
fields kind of feels like yeah it opens
up like could you and then the phone the
whole opportunity act right yeah yeah
the liquor license thing was something
we talked about there busting a
speakeasy cuisine right so again this
joy yeah thing is again if it sounds
like we're just or this challenge right
no the whole film is designed to incite
basically a logical race war that's
really what this film is design that's
what Gavin Bigelow is seeking to do do
you think you're gonna make anyone less
racist with this film you're probably
gonna get some kid from junior high
watch this in Detroit and go I knew it
call it go and just like one of these
just like Charles Cooper one of the guys
in here that they made it from the film
assault a teacher right that happened in
your school all the time teacher got
stabbed sure we had a an assistant
principal beaten within the first week
of the of the busing did she come back
she did she was tough old bird mrs. bird
mrs. Baird yeah its stocky gal but she
she had ganged up on they took her down
right because right after all these
these incidents they put you wanna put
you on a bus together it was it was the
year after I think this is time for
healing kids that's it bring the healing
and they sent they sent black kids to
white neighborhoods whose parents were
often police officers who they did not
like and that's the schools they came to
you got to be not quit a bit we had a
lot of trouble and typically oh yeah
well you took yours in the early years I
took alright early and often yeah I did
but it didn't seem to last too long it
seems like that experiment failed so
miserably
that they dialed it back pretty quick I
think it was two or three years in that
was well and that's what's so important
is they say like they were restricted
this is the idea there's white flight
and they were restricted to these areas
and so it was policy there was no policy
that blacks were restricted to an area
Detroit and again the same level of
income and wealth the wealthiest city in
the calm
three at that point so that is in all
its a bold-faced lie
yeah yeah and the whole opening amount a
lot of people need to know people need
to be aware the sleight of hand that
goes on there because it is pivotal and
critical to Kathryn Bigelow's entire
narrative yes they set it up that that
these people were forced here they even
make it sound like they moved to the
north for their like tricked into moving
to the north for the factory jobs yeah
right yeah so they move there
and they are cornered they are moved in
these neighborhoods they are restricted
according to kind of restricted when you
hear restricted yeah someone else was
restricting them no there was no law and
they have to say this all all these
things up they have to lean it all into
the favor of these poor black people had
no other choice what did you expect them
to do so they could dismiss all the
actions of the riots that follows so you
have to be like ah well I guess what
else did we expect and it's the racism
of low expectations at play yeah we all
agree if we if we were to start a
speakeasy and sell alcohol the middle
tonight Billy yeah or if I were to shoot
a starter pistol on an upstairs window
at cops repeatedly linking up shortly I
mean I don't care who you are yeah and
therefore to it is a toy gun like this
where the pistol is not a toy why it
works to start basis some may say that
was the purpose of him firing out the
window he might have said I'm gonna
teach these police a lesson Kabam bang
bang bang bang bang bang bang by the way
oh no no calm spoiler alert
at no point in is filming these people
are lined up they all lie they say what
did anyone that no one has a gun that we
know of officer look the whole situation
officers are terrible okay yeah we get
it not us using the officers but if I'm
in there I go home officer yeah you sell
that flesh it's that guy who now is is
dead on the floor of granted you screwed
up there but he did shoot the starter
pistol at me repeatedly from the top
floor starter pistol top floor right
there he was shooting at you I get it
because you've had sniper fire starter
pistol top floor I'm gonna be on my way
and get my lawyer it could have stopped
the whole thing but because the future
of no snitches yeah they don't talk to
the police
uh listen police are getting sniper fire
the liquor thing that was what set off
the rise in here they go yeah he says I
didn't do nothing hey you have no right
to treat us this way I think I just
listen you don't have a liquor license
it's a speakeasy
Gerald has jumped through hoops to get a
winery license and he does wine tasting
it's true to make sure like they again
it presumes that police officers only
Targ
people in one area of town of a specific
race yeah if you're a white guy in the
suburbs if you're a white guy who runs a
franchise Applebee's and you don't renew
your nick liquor license you're going
out in a paddy wagon and it's the
presumption from Kathryn Bigelow
white privilege immediately Detroit is
the result of a white systemic racism I
guess but they can't point to it
therefore let's focus on this story and
malign police officers and people had no
involvement with and that's why I say it
is it is head to toe proactive
propaganda
however the paddy wagons were named
after all those Irish that they hold out
named patty in the hayswood they were
discriminated against one might say it's
true they did but those drunken mix well
they had it coming
but he's mix connoisseur Irish it's got
its Scottish house is mix Scottish you
go through both in it I don't know but
you get my point okay anything else that
we missed I think something that I
thought about a lot about was you
mentioned this could have been a
learning opportunity for people say look
everybody there's a lot of screw-ups
yeah a lot of things that could have
been learned from all sides of it I
think one of the things that is forgot
often forgotten about that we taught is
sawn blatantly in the movie was they
were quick to showcase the culture of
silence that exists within the police
department which is a problem with his
approach which is a huge problem and yes
these people should be held to a much
higher standard than your everyday
citizens but there is also a culture of
science silence it happens that these
guys they had so many opportunity to say
yeah that guy right there they gonna
need a shot yeah he was buying out the
wooden to try to scare you all yes not
my idea with rival doubts because he was
the dead guy in the floor he was the
boss yeah I know what's funny is again
spoiler alert they leave and walk out
and this guy has a starter pistol and
fake shoots his friends and the girls
like I'm adding I'm not here like come
on it was just a joke the guy was
clearly a dick using his starter pistol
to scare people trying
he literally used it to trick people it
was convincing enough to be a real gun
yes that's what it sucked and they call
it a toy gun we got gnome now the
starter pistol was never recovered but
again if you look at the testimony
that's what it was it was a starter
pistol that's what started this and and
multiple times is important it wasn't
like bang oh gosh screw-up
oh yeah empty bang and then they shoot
out the streetlights cuz when where's
the sniper fire coming from
bang bang bang
then they see the flash coming from the
Super Soaker on the third floor Alger
motel and the gunshots and they Stormin
[ __ ] mistakes all around but again
what's important is they're telling one
story here okay I understand that you're
a filmmaker but they try to provide
context in a way like you said that has
nothing to do with Detroit the cotton
fields moving north world war two at no
point do they mention the actual direct
policies of Detroit to tell a personal
story they don't tell the personal story
of the folks these people have assaulted
the people who were alluded to black
people who were looted or there's a B&E
with one of the gentlemen they have long
long rap sheets does a president start
with the 1600s in Africa I'm surprised
didn't start the narrative there just to
build their case I know they said the
cotton field they went back pretty 95 to
talk about the early slave traders and
that doesn't fit there maybe shoot shoot
shoot shoot shoot shoot [ __ ] right there
you know Kathryn Bigelow was like okay
all these people seem like we can make
them squeaky clean so we can just make
the cops all bad except for one
mandatory so we can say hashtag not all
cops the whole film is with vilifying
cops okay here we go and then someone
said I'm sorry but these two women
actually had police records of being
prostitutes all right we'll just say it
like in passing you know what I know
we'll make the cop racist and he'll just
just we'll just he'll assume that she's
a prostitute cuz she was the black guy
so it will make the officers assume the
black guys a pimp and she's a prostitute
well never actually say that she's
really a prostitute
we'll make it seem like it's a pretty
ditional judgement so the whole film is
prop again again contextually I hope
people watch this instead of going out
outraged
what I hope happens and I hope if you
watch this review and you you know
someone who doesn't understand the
history of it roit send them our video
send them this review look contextually
from 1960 from the 50s actually look at
black Americans pre Detroit riots pre
Lyndon Johnson pre model cities pre
welfare program all the way go from the
1950s to today take all of that context
Detroit all of it everything mayor's
City Commission's police commissioners
senators everything every state senator
congressional to everyone who would have
any direct involvement in determining
the course that is Detroit
and then you tell me if this film seems
like an accurate representation also I
didn't like I think you guys liked it
more than I did I just the shaky cam
makes me nauseous
yeah I was a family I said wouldn't see
it again no I would know you know I'm
gonna really have a rating system pile
by this one's a pile of crap pile of
crap pile of crap on on a filmmaking
basis middle-of-the-road Miller rode on
a propaganda basis pile of crap big
steaming pile of crime say would you say
I would agree with that corn infested
sure I'm steaming sure all right that's
our view of Kathryn Bigelow's Detroit
Bigelow you can send your lawsuit to
sound guy Edward he deals with that now
hey if you like this clip you're like
most of the internet you have a short
attention span but it was taken from the
full show you can see it in the Box
playing next to me that's once a week on
Thursdays full one and a half hour show
or you can join the mug club for the
daily show we have to take some of that
off YouTube because they're monitoring
us and censoring her words